tiempo
y
como muchos sabrán en el último año del
colegio se acumulan todas las [ __ ]
por las cuales las empresas aprovechan y
nos sacan alrededor de un millón de
dólares a cada alumno con viaje de
egresados fiestas egresados abuso de
egresados cualquier producto que diga de
egresados al final etcétera pero esto no
nos toma solo nuestro último año sino
que empieza exactamente un año antes y
ahí es donde empieza mi historia
una pavada esencial de todo en estados
es el uso de egresados como dijeron por
supuesto el apodo no sé si todos los que
están acá vivieron esto pero todos
aunque algunos lo oculten queremos tener
ese apodo que nos guste que nos encante
y que encaje perfecto no era mi caso en
el de la mayoría de la clase pero bueno
vamos a hablar del mío
el año pasado fue uno muy especial en
donde las materias como historia me
preguntaba por qué las cosas eran o
fueron así un ejemplo que me acuerdo
perdón si es polémico era el de por qué
sarmiento está en un billete si en su
vida además de organizar todo el sistema
educativo del país perdón
había asesinado a grandes cantidades de
indios y gauchos visto esto con una
mirada actual se consideraría racista
pero a la mayoría de la clase no le
gustaba esta actitud mía de interrumpir
la clase para preguntar cosas que
básicamente nos enseñan así que
aprovechando la situación decidieron que
mi apodo tenía que ser filo de sartén
saben ustedes que hacen fila corten
no no no no yo no podía tener sapo ese
cartel en la espalda que cuando la gente
me preguntas el mío
yo tenía que responder eso no fue así
cuando surgió mi apodo un viernes a la
tarde en el taller de filosofía ya que
mi profesor tiene el mismo
este apoyo se asimilaba a filo de sartén
pero de una manera más sutil y positiva
este apodo encajada perfecto está apodo
era el salmón
ahora cuando la gente me pregunta el
porqué el mismo yo simplemente le digo
que la mayoría de los salmones son anna
dromos y que esto proviene el vocablo
griego anna drums que significa correr
hacia arriba cuando los salmones maduran
migran río arriba para desovar en lo que
se llama la carrera de los salmones los
huevos son capaces de incubar se sin
flotar o sin que se lo lleve la
corriente y los cardúmenes evitan que
los depredadores sean capaces de acceder
a los peces indefensos
es mentira solo les digo que nada en
contra de la corriente y algunos nenes
se quedan con cara de pero bueno desde
mi cualidades almona decidí hacer una
charla al respecto como le dije los
salmones deciden nadar en contra de la
corriente para desovar deciden nadar
encontrar la corriente para cumplir su
objetivo no les parece a ustedes que
nosotros deberíamos ser capaces de nadar
en contra de la corriente si es
necesario para cumplir nuestros
objetivos nada en contra de la corriente
con esto me refiero a tener una mirada
crítica tener la habilidad de tener un
pensamiento crítico sobre las cosas que
nos rodean poder cuestionar lo que está
impuesto por la sociedad pero para
concretar esto es necesario despertar
nuestro pensamiento crítico o sea
nuestro salmón la crítica tiene
connotación negativa sin embargo si
buscamos su definición en google podemos
ver que es un conjunto de juicios o
pensamientos que responden a un análisis
y que estos pueden ser negativos o
positivos la crítica positiva entonces
propone soluciones a problemas o
defectos que expongan la crítica misma
parece ser que al fin de cuentas no es
tan malo tener una mirada crítica no
pero qué pasa cuando decidimos acudir a
nuestro pensamiento crítico y ahí es
cuando nos encontramos con ese obstáculo
detestable e irritable los no críticos
saben ustedes que hacen los no críticos
se dedican a criticar a los críticos con
frases como las siguientes nada te viene
bien buscas el pelo al huevo sos una
persona negativa filo de sartén
cuestionas demasiado de vivir la vida
claramente la persona que dijo esto
último no estaban enteradas ni cerca de
que el colegio nos provee las
herramientas necesarias para poder
ejercitar nuestra mirada crítica del
mundo que nos rodea
pero porque el colegio quiere que seamos
personas críticas porque la crítica es
el motor de cambio raro no
la crítica es el motor de cambio pero
sin embargo nadie quiere ser un
engranaje ese motor las mayorías son no
críticas porque prefieren adherirse a lo
que está impuesto ser llegados por la
corriente estandarizarse no jugársela
para no terminar siendo personas
conflictivas o filos de sartenes quien
quiere eso no
gandhi galileo colon y millones de
personas más son la respuesta a esa
pregunta ellos decidieron ser personas
conflictivas salmones filos de sartenes
o como quieran llamarlo donde estaríamos
como sociedad si no fuese por nuestros
más grandes y mejores críticos si no
fuese por galileo hoy en día seguiríamos
pensando que todo gira alrededor de la
tierra incluyendo el sol qué ridículo no
algo que sale de tan chico igual
aconsejo no seguir completamente el
ejemplo de galileo y que es el salmón
sea la causa de tu ceguera pero sigamos
como no olvidar a colom a colom le
rechazaron dos veces su proyecto de
navegación para llegar a asia por otra
ruta
pero él no se rindió y así fue aceptado
por la corona española y esto bueno como
saben llevó a la conquista de américa
pero como no mencionar a la salmón as
que no sólo nadan en contra de la
corriente sino que nadan en contra del
machismo un gran ejemplo sería marie
curie científica polaca nacionalizada
francesa contra que nada ella contra la
depresión que le causó la muerte de su
hermana y su madre contra la represión
del imperio ruso en polonia contra la
pobreza que no le dejó pagar la
universidad de parís iii contra su
género que no la dejaron inscribirse en
un instituto de educación superior
porque era mujer y con toda esa
corriente encima siguió nadando y
terminó siendo la primera persona en
ganar dos premios nobeles de
especialidades distintas física y
química y la primera mujer en ocupar el
puesto de profesora en la universidad de
parís
ellos decidieron criticar no quedarse
quietos no aceptar el mundo tal como era
criticarlo y ahí poder transformarlos
decidieron ser un engranaje del motor de
cambio nadar en contra de la corriente y
no es coincidencia que terminaron siendo
grandes personajes en la historia del
mundo entonces para qué sirve la mirada
crítica como dije el pensamiento crítico
es el motor de cambio nosotros
deberíamos salir del colegio con ese
motor interno encendido así que si ya
saliste del colegio no no te quedes
quieto no te están narices jugate la
busca algo que te haga ruido y crítica
lo sé un engranaje del motor de cambio
nada en contra de la corriente
gandhi galileo colon marie curie rosa
parks frida kahlo decidieron ser
salmones
yo decidí ser salmón que te impide a vos
serlo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]